сьогодні поговоримо з вами про
криміналізацію контрабанди хочеш ти або
не хочеш Якщо говорити про діючі нормі
абсолютно чітко виписано про те що є
кримінальна відповідальність за
контрабанду товарів яких товарів саме це
зброя це наркотики це різні культурні
цінності це класичний підхід до
контрабанди в країнах Європейського
Союзу також Що
запропонувала Влада
товарну
контрабанду ввести відповідальність в
Кримінальний кодекс це діяння є
кримінально караним і за нього будуть
нести відповідальність можливо Хтось
скаже що це добре Та коли ми почали
розбиратися з кожною нормою
запропонованого проекту закону
Виявляється що абсолютно в надуманий
спосіб по відношенню до любого
підприємця підприємства і великого
підприємства Великого
експортера-імпортера можна знайти завжди
підстави для того щоб притягнути його до
цієї кримінальної відповідальності вже
за яку передбачено не тільки штраф А іще
і роки тюрми і я все від себе залежне
зроблю щоб це зроби щоб це відбулося що
таке товарна контрабанда ось
переміщується через митний
кордон через пункти пропуску чи поза
пунктами пропуску якісь товари
розглядаємо питання от їде товар через
пункт пропуску і через митницю Ну звісно
може бути прихований товар в р в різних
тайниках зроблених там пристосованих в
автомобілях та якихось там відсіках і
так далі чи передбачена за це
відповідальність зараз звісно
передбачена це норми Митного кодексу які
передбачають конфіскацію такого товару і
конфіскацію оцих сховищ Якщо таким схови
є сам транспортний засіб то він також
підлягає конфіскації нараховується
санкція і конфіскований товар також
згодом за рішенням суду
реалізовується Мені здається що ступінь
покарання доволі висока і після введення
таких значних санкцій Ну насправді ці
норми Митного кодексу є дієвими До речі
Україна єдина держава в Європі і у
всесвітній митній організації митні
органи якої не наділені функціями
досудового розслідування і Ми весь час
були незадоволені а де ж ефективна
робота митниці і говорили для того щоб
вона була нам потрібно прибрати звідти
всі ці підрозділи правоохоронних органів
і надати митниці право слідства як це у
всіх країнах А які цілі перед собою
ставила держава чи ініціатори
впровадження кримінальної
відповідальності за перевезення товарів
з порушеннями тут прослідковується одна
єдина ціль завдання яке стоїть - це
несла негласні слідчі дії тобто
підцепити підприємця підприємство на
гачок І вести його шантажувати його це
передусім удар ножем в спину абсолютно
ми маємо розуміти що це буде
прослуховування
всіх можливих ліній зв'язку абсолютно
точно
будуть вилучення документів це не то що
Маски шоу А це збільшеному варіанті тиск
на бізнес який буде застосовуватись я в
цьому просто впевнена То хто ж буде
здійснювати контроль Ну звісно це буде
бюро економічної безпеки Ви що собі
придумали беб який ви кожного дня
згадуєте як самий неефективний
правоохоронний орган який точно не буде
зараз переформатований оновлений взагалі
його треба ліквідовувати і створювати
новий Ну звісно ці норми приймаються
виключно під цей орган який є абсолютно
не то що слухняним він повністю
підпорядкований офісу президенту він
повністю під татаровим був є і
залишиться татарова ніхто не збирається
знімати тому ця вся історія буде
крутитися навколо того що це ще один
інструмент поставити завдання конкретно
по якомусь підприємст
уже деє кримінальна відповідальність у
вигляді позбавлення волі виконую
доручення президента України і керівника
офісу президента так і Отже Виходить так
що з 1 липня 2024 року наш багато
обговорений нездібний непридатний до
насправді захисту економічних інтересів
країни беб буде проводити слідчі дії
гласні і негласні по відношенню до
встановлення кримінальних правопорушень
по ввезенню
контрабанди за 248 рішення прийнято
Закон прийнятий в
цілому після прийняття відразу пішла
новина по економічним ЗМІ те що раніше
два трошки більше двох років нещадно
критикувалося зараз замовчується зовсім
саме уряд проводить міжнародні
переговори щодо наших щодо тих хто
фінансує і допомагає фінансувати нашу
економіку А ми як позичальник маємо все
ж таки враховувати їх думку і
передбачати в поточному законодавстві Я
хотіла би заперечити що цей закон не є
вимогою МВФ це не є ніяким структурним
маяком в країнах Європи взагалі за
економічні злочини передбачена
економічна відповідальність це
економічний злочин звісно економічний
тому що не сплачуються митні платежі в
цьому Вся суть контролю який
здійснюється на митниці в 24х країнах
Європейського Союзу у багатьох випадках
термін кримінальна санкція означає лише
те що відповідне покарання
встановлюється судом а не рішенням
митного органу і фактично у вітчизняному
розумінні може бути адміністративним
штрафом абсолютно всі дії
які робить Влада вони просто свідчать
про те що влада бізнесу не довіряє Влада
хоче контролювати кожний крок
прослуховувати
відслідковувати робити все можливе і
неможливе щоб вичавлювати більше з тих
хто ще працює в Україні Ну це зовсім не
наша політика такого не може бути під
час війни такого взагалі не може бути в
країні з ринковою економікою з
економікою яка е Мені дуже сумно
спостерігати за діями цієї Верховної
Ради Я впевнена що згодом ми будемо
переглядати повністю кримінальну
відповідальність по товарній контрабанді
кожен крок буде відчутний бізнесу на
жаль але ми маємо гуртуватися змінювати
і робити все можливе для того щоб ми не
були
пригнічені як не хотілось би називати
але в Сідні країні